restez avec nous lors ans elle vous fera
du bien d'écouter un peu je vais
répondre à toutes vos questions
mais avant je vais vous dire une chose
je n'accepterai jamais la multiplication
ridicule des autorités dites
indépendantes qui sont le cancer de
notre pays indépendante depuis
indépendante de quoi nous sommes dans
une démocratie dans une démocratie on
vote et les responsables politiques vont
arrêter de déléguer leurs
responsabilités sur des autorités
prétendument indépendante qui n'ont
aucune légitimité que les responsables
politiques assument avec courage de
conviction
ça c'est une politique voilà et je
pourrais multiplier les exemples
et si les français ne sont pas contents
ils changent la majorité avec les
autorités indépendantes qui n'ont aucune
légitimité
qui est responsable personne 2e romain
nous ne sommes pas un groupe
d'intellectuels
nous sommes des citoyens français qui
veulent qu'ils préparent l'alternance et
qui veulent des réformes qui rentre dans
les faits la question n'est pas d'être
libéral ou pas la question d'avoir une
école qui répondent aux attentes des
familles et d'avoir une université qui
répondent aux attentes des étudiants
je vais rentrer en détail là dedans dit
il ya des conservateurs chez vous bien
sûr partout pourquoi ils n'auraient pas
chez nous il y en a même dans votre four
nations connaît
alors merci eric woerth
merci annie genevard merci dominique
nachury merci madeleine de gizeh merci
olivier vial merci jean baptiste de
froment
merci à daniel fasquelle l'ailier marc
l'ex patrick hetzel
puis andré périssol tous ceux laurent
bigorgne tous ceux françois-xavier
lamige csu parti dans un truc
épouvantable
tous ceux qui ont accepté de travailler
avec nous il ya un lien indissoluble
entre la république et les et l'école et
ce lien explique la passion des français
pour la question scolaire et d'ailleurs
les sentiments que vous mettez les uns
et les autres dans ce débat ce que même
quand on n'est pas tout à fait d'accord
il ya la passion parce qu'il ya un lien
indissoluble entre l'école au sens large
et la république
le constat malheureusement c'est
qu'aujourd'hui nous sommes face à un
échec de la réussite éducative pour
employer les grands mots mais il faut
employer les mots qui conviennent
nous sommes face un échec pas de cap pas
de politique pas de vision ces quatre
dernières années l'éducation nationale a
et les deux ministres ministres trois
ministres en quatre ans dire qu'ils
connaissaient à peine le chemin de son
bureau
qui a été changée chacun déclaré forme
rythmes scolaires réforme des programmes
et plans des collèges je vous posais la
question que reste-t-il
je cite de la refondation de l'école
annoncé à grand renfort de communication
par vincent peillon
il reste la catastrophique réforme des
rythmes scolaires est un espèce de méli
mélo idéologique ou la seule
préoccupation de l'éducation nationale
devrait être que les enfants ne
s'ennuient pas la seule politique
constante de ce gouvernement emprise
idéologique et je veux le dire emprise
syndical on m'a appelé à ne pas avoir d'
à bout et au panama
j'ajoute que ce gouvernement a mis
beaucoup d'énergie pour déconstruire des
dispositifs éducatifs qui fonctionnait
au seul motif qu'ils avaient mis été mis
en place par l'ancienne majorité
j'aimerais que par françois un peu plus
fier de ce qu'on a fait parce que
c'était pas si facile les internats
d'excellence
je me demande encore qui a pu conseiller
à ce gouvernement de les supprimer je
suis fier des internats d'excellence du
mot internat et de l'excellence des deux
soyons fiers de ce qu'on a fait
la loi contre l'absentéisme scolaire
ça c'est une loi sociale avec à la clé
suppression des allocations familiales
suspension suppression pour les familles
qui ne signalait pas l'absenté de leurs
enfants
j'en suis fier mais qui a pu conseiller
la suppression des classes bilangues que
nous avions créé et développé et
encourager qui a pu conseiller chez
olivier la suppression des bourses au
mérite
on est confondu devant cette action de
démolition dont la seule raison c'est le
sectarisme idéologique la seule qu'elle
fut la priorité pour l'éducation
nationale de cette majorité
60000 postes le mot magique
la seule réponse à la question de
l'échec scolaire elle et quantitatives
alors que les statistiques
internationales le prouve
l'éducation nationale française ne
manque pas de moyens si on la compare à
nos voisins européens selon elle manque
c'est le résultat
il ya cent mille jeunes qui sortent
chaque année sans diplôme de la
scolarité est pas moins d'un élève sur
cinq qui sort du collège sans maîtriser
les fondamentaux
non nous allons faire des propositions
très forte précise charles aux roms ne
serai pas déçu que vous soutiendrez avec
l'enthousiaste que je vous connais et la
confiance toujours manifesté des signes
tank de droite et du centre à la droite
de droite et de saintes
alors d'abord un problème de conception
l'école pour nous de répondre aux mêmes
valeurs que la société que nous voulons
la société à laquelle nous aspirons
sur le pen société sans histoire sans
travail sans effort sans récompense sans
distinction à l'école non plus notre
vision de l'école est fondée sur les
mêmes principes que la vision que nous
avons la société nous ne voulons pas
d'une école qui tire tout le monde vers
le bas
nous n'en voulons pas nous pensons que
la médiocrité que l'égalitarisme à tous
les niveaux y compris pour les concours
de dagris g où on définit le nombre de
besoins là et on fait passer les gens
qui ont 7 de moyenne
à tout lire oui enfin ça c'est pas la
meilleure référence parce que y'avait
pardon y aurait beaucoup à dire
là-dessus pardon jean baptiste beaucoup
à dire nous ne voulons pas d'une école
sans notes
nous ne voulons pas d'une école où on
explique que le maître est légal de
l'élève dans l'apprentissage et la
transmission des savoirs
nous ne voulons pas d'une école qui ni
l'effort le mérite
la récompense alors pour nous il ya
quatre ans de mission fondamentale
transmission des savoirs développement
de l'excellence l'excellence est pas un
gros mot rétablissement de l'autorité
on peut parler de toutes les réformes
que l'on veut sans autorité il n'y aura
aucun résultat possible
la crise de l'autorité dans notre
société et dans notre école est le coeur
du problème est bien sûr autonomie j'y
reviendrai en détail alors d'abord je
veux qu'on fait c'est une erreur comme
beaucoup pendant des années j'ai cru que
l'on devait partir pour la réforme de
l'école de l'enfant je pense que c'est
une fausse bonne idée
je vais m'en expliquer d'autres je crois
que la première question c'est celle des
enseignants
carc
que soit la qualité de la réforme que
vous mettrez sur la table si vous avez
des enseignants qui ne croient plus dans
leur métier qui ne sont pas rémunérés
qui ne sont pas bien formés qui ne sont
pas bien encadré qui ne sont pas évalués
la réforme sera un échec
le premier changement cardinal que nous
les républicains gerani nous proposons
c'est que la future réforme de l'école p
andry au sens large partie des
enseignants des maîtres appelez les
comme vous voulez et non pas des enfants
cela ne veut pas dire familles de france
que je ne considère pas les enfants
comme le coeur les dispositifs cela veut
dire que la première question c'est
celle de la réhabilitation du métier
d'enseignant de la considération du
métier d'enseignant de la rémunération
du métier d'enseignant du respect de
l'autorité du métier d'enseignant de
l'évaluation du métier d'enseignant et
quand il est pas bon être sanctionné de
la présence de l'enseignant avec les
enfants et non pas d'un absentéisme
invraisemblable voilà la première
orientation de notre projet
isabelle pour l'éducation c'est
l'enseignant alors ap
mais ces gens reconnaît bien volontiers
que je n'ai pas toujours dit ça j'ai
plus graves je n'ai pas toujours penser
ça c'est vraiment le retour d'expérience
je pense qu'il faut qu'on change notre
triste et je le dis d'ailleurs à tous
les enseignants de france tellement déçu
par le bilan accablant de la gauche que
nous voulons nous adresser à chacun
d'eux non pas pour des raisons
politiques
nous voulons adresser à chacun d'eux
parce que nous sommes parfaitement
conscients que nous avons besoin
d'enseignants respecter et qui est des
enfants dans la classe des enseignants
qui se disent un jour je rêve d'être à
la place du maître
parce que si aucun enfant ne 20 jours
vers le travail du maître
comment voulez-vous que celui ci soit
respectée et comment voulez vous que les
enseignants trouvent dans la société
la place à laquelle ils ont droit alors
cela pose un premier problème qui est
problème de la formation
là aussi je que les choses soient
claires entre nous nous avons mis fin
aux yeux fm
je le regrette nullement car lui-même
préparé les enseignants à tout sauf à ça
je peux être désagréable mais je
pourrais c'est la première idée
la deuxième idée c'est que je suis
toujours convaincu je me battrai là
dessus que le lieu de formation des
enseignants ce doit être une université
pourquoi parce que mes chers amis c'est
l'université ne forme pas nous mettre le
maître de nos enfants
quelle confiance la république peut
avoir dans l'université donc je ne
regrette pas ces changements mais je
dois reconnaître que nous ne sommes pas
allés assez loin sur l'étape
indispensable qu'elle tu te ra et
l'apprentissage du métier d'enseignant
au contact même des enfants
est-ce que je j'ai c'est de bien me
faire comprendre
je ne crois pas aux iufm ou à ce qu'ils
ont fait jusqu'à présent
je crois à l'université mais je pense
qu'on n'a pas été assez loin sur la
partie non pas théorique des savoirs des
maîtres mais sur la partie tout simple
de savoir enseigner et pour ça le
tutorat sur les cinq années d'études
la présence au moins pendant une année
au contact d'une classe avec un
enseignant qui sert de twitter
je crois que c'est absolument
indispensable
j'ajoute qu'on peut pas continuer à
affecter les plus jeunes professeurs
dans les établissements les plus
difficiles sans encadrement sans
préparation et quinze jours il faudra
bien se poser la question est ce qu'on
ne doit pas payer un peu plus des
enseignants qui accepteraient d'aller
dans les lycées et les collèges les
écoles les plus difficiles plutôt qui m
les plus jeunes sans expérience
excusez moi je pense la même chose je
donne je pense exactement la même chose
pour les médecins je pense que pour le
même acte quand un médecin accepte de
dispenser son savoir dans une région de
désert médical il est normal qu'ils
soient rémunérés davantage pour le même
acte et je pense qu'un enseignant qui
accepteraient de prendre à sa charge un
collège un lycée une classe plus
difficile
il est normal de le rémunérer davantage
plutôt que dire d'accord les plus jeunes
qui ont moins d'expérience qui ont moins
de points vous êtes des derniers vous
allez d'ailleurs faire vos dents avec
les plus difficiles et c'est comme ça
qu'on accroît les inégalités scolaires
deuxième orientation très forte
tout le monde le sait plutôt intervient
sur l'échec scolaire plus efficace on
est ce que je dis aucune originalité
mais maintenant on va passer du concept
non à la réalité
notre idée est assez simple
l'apprentissage de la lecture c'est cp
ce1 théoriquement ccp mais beaucoup
savent que
ça peut continuer en sait en tout cas il
ya un point qui fait absolument
consensus c'est qu'un enfant qui sort du
cp et du ce1 pour passer en cours
élémentaire 1 ou 2 sans savoir lire
il va stocker de l'échec scolaire et n'a
aucune chance de s'en sortir
aucune c'est pas parce qu'on sait lire
qu'on va réussir
mais si on ne sait pas lire dans cette
époque
à cette étape essentielle du cours
préparatoire ou du cours élémentaire
première année ne rentrant pas dans le
débat pour savoir si ces ce1 ou cp on
est fichu on va accumuler de l'échec
donc notre idée c'est de repérer tout de
suite tout enfants du cp qui n'arrive
pas à lire et de créer les conditions de
ce qu'on appellerait conditionnelle un
cp + ou un ce1 plus qu'ils prendraient
tous ces enfants qui n'arrive pas à lire
pour les soutenir pour la lecture et ne
faire passer en co2 que des enfants qui
savent parfaitement maîtriser la lecture
c'est un choix très fort c'est un choix
structurants
c'est un choix social je vois très bien
qu'on va me dire que c'est un choix de
sélection c'est tout le contraire
parce que vous rendez compte que c'est
les enfants qui aux alentours de 6 ans 7
ans je sais très bien que le
redoublement ne sert à rien parce qu'un
redoublement consiste à refaire faire le
même parcours d'échec dans les mêmes
conditions
ce que nous proposons gerani est tout à
fait différent on y en a combien d % 15
% des statistiques ne peuvent pas dire
la vérité mais en tout cas tous ceux qui
souffrent qui sont en souffrance mois 30
sièges à lecture on les met dans les
petites classes on les soutient avec des
heures y compris l'été on leur demande
d'aller suivre des cours de soutien la
lecture mais il ya une chose qui est
sûre dans l'école de la république
trahan en ce2 en sachant parfaitement
lire voilà ce qu'attendent les français
voilà alors je ne suis pas sûr ça fait
andré qu'il faut la même comment comment
dire la même règle partout autonomie ça
veut dire que dans chaque école ils
seront libres de déterminer qui sait
lire qui sait pas lire ça devrait pas
être très compliqué quand même est libre
de disposer de moyens pour voir comment
on sort un gosse qui n'arrive pas à lire
de cette situation d'échec avant de le
faire passer en 6 e 2 est ce que
monsieur bien fait comprendre qu'il ya
un premier sujet qui est la rémunération
j'y reviendrai la place etc à des
enseignants deuxième sujet l'échec
scolaire
notre idée c'est d'intervenir dès le cp
et de donner à tous les jeunes enfants
de france
la capacité de passer en co2 que s'il
s'appelait et là je pense que c'est un
un changement absolument considérable
s'agissant du collège première chose
assez facile abrogation complète du
projet de réforme de l'actuelle ministre
on fait comment imaginer
que les enseignements pratiques
interdisciplinaire puissent être
conservés écoutez une chose qui est sûre
professeur de france familles de france
ce problème sera réglé assez vite réglé
par la suppression de tout ça ensuite je
pense qu'il faut sortir des débats
intellectuels pardo collège unique ou
pas parce que dans ce don de mon point
de vue
l'éducation nationale souffre de débats
idéologiques souffre de débats
politiciens souffre de débat de postures
il ya plus en plus d'enfants qui
viennent
ils sont plus en plus différents et il
faut des réponses de plus en plus
adaptée chaque établissement doit
pouvoir offrir des filières diversifiée
moi je crois aux classes bilangues enfin
quand on voit les résultats dramatiques
en termes de langue étrangère des
lycéens français supprimés les classes
bilangues les sections européennes
c'est absurde de la même façon qu'ils
aucune raison de supprimer les options
de langues anciennes et parallèlement
nous voulons ouvrir les filières de
préapprentissage dès 14 ans
je ne vois pas pourquoi on doit attendre
16 ans l'âge de 14 ans me paraît sofac
aussi sauf si on considère que
l'apprentissage chez déchoir et dans ce
cas là mesdames et messieurs mes chers
amis si c'est déchoir l'apprentissage
c'est pas plus juste à 16 ans c'est pas
plus juste à 18 ans soit l'apprentissage
est une filière d'excellence et dans ce
cas là elle n'est pas moins 14 ans ou à
16 ans soit c'est une filière dont il
faut se débarrasser
et dans ce cas-là n'ayons pas le tabou
de l'âge nous nous croyons dans
l'apprentissage
nous y croyons totalement et celles à
présent pour qu'elle nous faisons cette
proposition alors j'ajoute que nous
proposons un changement très fort je
suis assez
fasciné de voir qu'un jeune qui ne
réussit pas en lycée général on l'envoie
en lycée professionnel
la différence entre le lycée général du
lycée professionnel c'est que c'est un
lycée est donc le jeune qui est pas à
l'aise pour toutes a pas de raison dans
le lycée excusez moi il est deux pas
plus à l'aise dans un lycée
professionnel dans un lycée général
surtout si on lui a expliqué qu'ils
passaient d'un lycée de première
division
un lit cette deuxième division je ne me
comprenez moi je ne dis pas loin de moi
cette idée que le lycée professionnel
non mais on dévalorise la filière
professionnelle donc on a tous les
inconvénients mais en même temps pour le
jeune qui est pas à l'aise dans la
classe qui est pas les au lycée on le
met dans un lycée général et lycée
professionnel et 75% de nos jeunes au
niveau bac professionnel passe par le
lycée 25% par l'apprentissage en
allemagne qui doit être un exemple 75 %
arrivent au niveau du bac professionnel
par l'apprentissage seulement 25% par
lycée professionnel nous devons nous
inspirer de cet équilibre et changer
complètement la logique des choses
par ailleurs la question du mérite va
nous amener à rétablir les bourses au
mérite pour les bacheliers mention très
bien j'avais voulu que ceux qui se
donnent plus de mal que les autres
oui je sais c'est très grave c'est un
raisonnement peu particulier soit plus
récompensé que les autres la gauche l'a
supprimée parce que quand on récompense
ceux qui se donnent plus de mal on
risque de blesser ce qui se donne le
moins de mal
mais je souhaite madeleine qui en a
parlé qu'on aille plus loin et que nous
sortions de la logique des bourses
attribuées sur des seuls critères
sociaux je suis désolé la question des
classes moyennes exactement olivier est
centrale pour l'avenir économique de
notre pays
les classes moyennes c'est très simple
ils sont trop riches pour et pauvres
trop propre trop pauvre pour être riche
et en tout cas ils ont jamais le droit
des bourses jamais droit à rien eh bien
je propose que d'enchères années que
dans notre projet nous assumions qu'il y
ait des bourses d'excellence sur le seul
critère du mérite et cher laurent
qu'elle soit très déconcentré puisque je
voudrais qu au niveau du rectorat
il y ait la location d'un contingent de
bourse qui serait affectée est décidée
par chaque établissement
vous voyez la révolution on ne tient pas
compte simplement des critères sociaux
on affecte un contingent une allocation
à chaque rectorat qui est le répartit
entre les établissements
mais c'est les établissements eux mêmes
qui décident de qui sont les lycéens les
collégiens les écoliers qui ont droit
aux bourses
vous voyez qu'on renforce l'autorité de
ses équipes pédagogiques et que l'on
donne de l'autonomie naturellement le
programme des internats d'excellence
sera repris il s'agit pas du tout mes
chers amis de le reprendre parce que je
l'avais voulu ça n'a aucun sens j'ai
moi-même même écrit pour dire ce que je
regrettais dans certains cas d'avoir
fait mais les internats d'excellence
ça donne la possibilité à des enfants
pour le coup de familles modestes où il
n'y a même pas une table je parle même
pas de d'une chambre pour eux ou par
foyer le soir y'a pas de dîner de
pouvoir être toute la semaine dans un
environnement propice pour pouvoir faire
valoir leur volonté de réussir
supprimez les internats d'excellence
c'était un scandale un scandale social
jeu le titre parce que je pense et c'est
pas du tout à mes côtés c'est essentiel
alors bien sûr dans l'éducation
nationale tout est centralisé
il faut donner de la proximité et de la
liberté au système à l'école l'autonomie
n'a pas le même sens qu'à l'université
je vais venir
mais qu'on ne se trompe pas je refuse
l'autogestion je refuse la mise sous
tutelle d'une école sous un pouvoir
syndical ou sur une coterie quelle
qu'elle soit libérons l'éducation
nationale de ces pressions
qui peut accepter en 2016 que les
promotions des enseignants les
affectations des enseignants soient
donnés par les syndicats qui informent
leurs mandants et qui ici pourrait me
dire n'est ce pas pire andré que ce
n'est pas vrai que parfois on doit
prendre la carte d'un syndicat parce
qu'on attend un poste ce n'est pas ça la
république la république c'est la
neutralité et la république ne peut pas
accepter la mainmise syndicales sur un
appareil
daniel ça ne veut pas dire qu'ils vont
pas de syndicat mondial
qu'on ne vienne pas m'en faire le procès
mais justement les syndicats sont
tellement importants c'est pas aux
syndicats de gérer l'éducation nationale
il y en a pas attendre un poste doit
obtenir un poste en fonction de la carte
d'un parti politique ou la carte d'un
syndicat alors l'autonomie c'est une
plus grande liberté de gestion
d'organisation qui ne doit pas remettre
en cause la transmission des savoirs
ni la place accordée aux disciplines ni
le caractère national de l'éducation des
petits la mini c'est une question ça
alors bien sûr parce que si on n'avait
pas me faire le rang ça voudrait dire
que la majorité qui va sortir des urnes
en 2017 n'aurait donc pas de politique
universitaire je veux que nous et une
politique universitaire je veux pousser
une politique d'éducation nationale
comme on doit avoir une politique pénale
comme on doit avoir une politique
économique comme on doit avoir une
politique fiscale comme on doit avoir
une politique sociale et c'est
certainement pas
érudit ou 10 avant qu'ils vont se
retrouver dans un petit bureau en se
regardant parce qu'ils sont bac + 25 et
patrice 32 et qui vont déterminer ce
qu'est la politique universitaire et
éducative d'un pays soit on a des
convictions en a pas vous avez compris
je suis pas bac + 32 bon alors d'abord
je crois à la déconcentration sous le
contrôle du recteur s'agissant du chef
d'établissement
là nous allons proposer un changement
très fort car on a beaucoup discuté
aujourd'hui le chef d'établissement
je pense maternelle et primaire n'est
qu'un enseignant parmi les autres et
aussi curieux que cela puisse paraître
il n'a aucun pouvoir d'autorité
d'évaluation moi je souhaite que les
directeurs soit des directeurs qui
pilote le rétablissement qui est un
pouvoir d'évaluation et qu'il est même
un pouvoir de sanction
je ne connais pas une organisation
humaine qui puisse fonctionner sans qu'à
sa tête et un chef chef d'établissement
principal proviseur
vous voyez le recteur doit avoir plus
d'autonomie
le directeur doit avoir une autorité sur
l'équipe pédagogique qui est la sienne
je pense que la région académique doit
être le centre de gravité des décisions
en matière éducative naturellement any
two peut pas décider d'un bureau de la
rue de gonnehem alors cette réforme des
structures doit s'accompagner d'un sujet
extrêmement sensible
mais enfin la crédibilité de
l'alternance viendra de notre capacité à
assumer des choix sensible sinon le rend
mal à faire preuve de courage
écoutez
le courage c'est de dire que la présence
des enseignants dans les établissements
ne peut plus limité aux seules heures de
classe je veux être bien je veux être
sûr d'être bien compris il ne s'agit
nullement dans notre projet n'est ce pas
madeleine d'augmenter le nombre d'heures
de classe de vos enfants
il s'agit simplement d'augmenter la
durée de présence des enseignants dans
les établissements scolaires pour
soutenir vos enfants qui n'ont pas en
classe pu accéder au minimum
d'information et de compréhension
le problème de nos collèges et nos
lycées c'est qu'après la classe il n'ya
plus d'adultes dans l'établissement
qu'ils sont laissés à eux-mêmes et tout
le monde n'a pas la chance d'avoir des
petits courts que la famille peut payer
ou d'avoir sa mère qui vous attend à
16h30 toiture vous faites votre devoir
le temps de présence des enseignants
doit donc être augmenté de 25% et se
répartir entre le temps de classe et le
temps de soutien aux élèves
je crois que l'expression convenue ses
obligations de service et que
naturellement ça nous conduira à
augmenter la rémunération des
enseignants
il n'est pas question d'augmenter la
rémunération si on n'augmente pas le ton
travail
il n'est pas question d'augmenter le
temps de travail sans augmenter la
rémunération est ce que je me fais bien
comprendre leurs pattes
après on a été à plus loin
n'est ce pas mon cher eric je ne sais
pas si vous rentrez dans ce détail
15h d'obligations de service pour les
agrégés 18 eur d'obligations de service
pour les certifiés 24 eur d'obligations
de service pour les enseignants
maternelles et primaires on verra
comment répartir les choses ce que nous
souhaitons c'est qu'il y ait une
présence des adultes dans
l'établissement renforcé et que
notamment la totalité des collégiens et
des lycéens puissent faire leurs devoirs
à l'école sous le régime des titres
surveiller et d'études encadrer la docta
hallyday ce qui est un changement
considérable par rapport à ce que nous
connaissions alors s'ajoute maintenant
le problème de l'autorité alors
l'autorité ça doit d'abord et de celles
du ministre
et naturellement il est le garant de
l'égalité des chances pour tous les
français j'ai répondu sur le ministre
éducation nationale je ne pourrais pas
accepter une majorité qui se
désintéresserait de la politique
universitaire de la politique scolaire
de la pratique d'éducation nationale et
qui laisse un frère un collège de
savants mais il est important de
rappeler que s'il ministre arrête les
programmes
ceux ci doivent être préparées par
l'inspection générale et je souhaite
qu'il puisse être utilement transmis
pour avis un institut de france on a
quand même là des institutions dans la
qualité intellectuelle n'est mise en
cause par personne et il serait quand
même utile de les interroger de temps en
temps sur un certain nombre de sujets le
rétablissement de l'autorité à l'école
ça nous amène à parler de laïcité
l'école est un lieu neutre qui garantit
la sécurité de chaque enfant et qui ne
tolèrent ou ne devrait tolérer ni
communautarisme idéologie alors là je
l'admets ait un débat et ce départ n'est
pas celui qu'on croit
il est entre ce dont nous sommes qui
pensons que la situation est très grave
par rapport aux montées communautariste
et ce que je respecte qui pensent que
c'est pas si grave que ça et que la
liberté individuelle doit primer sur la
laïcité et la neutralité la république
donc au nom de la liberté individuelle
on peut dire au pour qu'on en fait une
jeune fille bien vouloir au nom de la
république
on ne peut pas accepter des pratiques
confessionnelles et communautaristes
dans des lieux scolaires que ce soit le
collège maternelle la primaire le lycée
et l'université
je ne vois pas où autrefois on devrait
tolérer à l'université ce qu'on
interdirait aux collèges la question
mais on rien la question n'étant rien de
porter à l'atteinte à la liberté de
chacun chacun peut prendre le métro venu
comme il veut mais dans les lieux
scolaires la république ne tolère aucun
signe distinctif d'appartenance à une
religion ou à une communauté parce que
mes chers amis
disons les choses comme elles sont et
mettons les pieds dans le plat
aujourd'hui il s'agit pas de préserver
une minorité contre la majorité il
s'agit de préserver la majorité contre
minorité agissante qui vit on la laisse
faire imposera à la majorité des choix
qui ne sont pas les siens c'est ça la
vérité c'est ça le courage ça ne veut
pas dire que je ne respecte pas la
liberté individuelle module peu et
habillés comme on veut chez soi on peut
se promener comme on veut dans les
locaux publics et l'université c'est les
locaux publics
on ne porte pas de signes religieux et
j'ajoute que nous pouvons accepter aucun
menus confessionnels et que nous ne
pouvons pas accepter qu'à l'hôpital
on exige un médecin femme quand on est
une femme qu'à la piscine on exige des
heures pour les femmes et des heures
pour les indes
je suis désolé on est sur la république
française et dans la république
française
on a les mêmes médecins on s'habille
pareil
et on ne fait aucune concession aucune
concession sur ces questions alors c ran
et excusez-moi j'ai peut être trop long
mais comme vous voyez on est passionné
parce que ce design on a le droit d'être
passionné quand même c'est pas
uniquement que des sujets techniques
c'est une passion parce que c'est nos
enfants c'est l'avenir notre pays alors
on a eu un grand débat sur uniforme pas
uniforme tout ça mon idée c'est
l'autonomie mais l'essai au conseil
d'administration de chaque établissement
la liberté de décider quels sont les
codes vestimentaires
c'est au conseil d'administration c'est
à l'équipe pédagogique représentants des
familles représentant enfin de décider
écoutez cette maladie française de
penser que l'unité c'est l'uniformité
je ne le parle la partage pas il faut au
même titre de l'autonomie les mêmes qui
le disent plus d'autonomie
pourquoi pas lui nu l'uniforme add ons
mais si c'est l'autonomie laisser les
choisir et on peut parfaitement avoir un
conseil d'administration ici qui décide
qui aura pas de casque est là qui décide
que ça les gêne d'avoir des tennis là
qui décident autre chose mais que ce
soit le conseil d'établissement
le conseil d'administration de
l'établissement qui décident librement
je voudrais également vous dire que nous
proposerons l'extinction des dispositifs
locaux les dispositifs locaux
c'est l'enseignement des langues des
communautés d'origine excusez moi la
langue de la république française et le
français si on veut apprendre d'autres
langues
on apprend d'autres langues il ya des
possibilités mais je ne pense pas qu'on
favorise l'intégration des français dans
notre pays en les maintenant dans
l'obligation de d'apprendre la langue de
leurs parents c'est un choix qui peut
être personnel que je respecte tout à
fait dans ce cas là il ya des
associations et c'est pas à l'école de
la république de s'en occuper que
l'école de la république apprendre à nos
enfants à lire à écrire et à compter
et à lire en français alors bien sûr
l'autorité c'est l'échelle des sanctions
et là vous allez voir enfin des
propositions bien sûr une fois qu'on l'a
dit pour rétablir l'autorité je
reconnais bien volontiers qu'on n'a pas
fait grand chose aujourd'hui le chef
d'établissement a le choix entre
l'exclusion pour des élèves qui viennent
pas c'est à dire qu'on passe d'un autre
sans théisme il l'est gagnent un
absentéisme légal non mais ça fait qu'un
jour tu viens pas je te mets dehors
trois jours ça fera 18 jours voyez le
truc ça n'a absolument aucun sens alors
voilà ce que nous proposons d'instituer
de nouvelles formes de punition qui
seraient prévues par le règlement
intérieur pour les premiers refus
d'autorité travaux d'intérêt général ça
me paraît tout à fait nécessaires allant
jusqu'à obligations de stages de
rattrapage jusqu'à la possibilité d'être
contraint à aller vers un établissement
de réinsertion scolaire qui serait un
internat autrement dit des jeunes qui ne
voudrait pas comprendre que la société
que la république ne peut pas accepter
qu'ils mettent la pagaille dans un
établissement ou qu'il n'est plus au
cours nous allons mettre en place des
établissements de réinsertion scolaire
que nous avions initiée à titre
expérimental en 2010 initiative
naturellement interrompu par l'actuel
gouvernement
je voudrais qu'il y en ait au moins deux
par académie et un jeune qui ne
comprendraient pas que l'école est
obligatoire
ou alors j'ai pas le droit
on doit aller à l'école eh bien il
pourrait se retrouver dans un
établissement d'internât de réinsertion
scolaire avec encadrement renforcé
naturellement s'agissant de mineurs les
parents devraient être d'accord et si
les parents ne sont pas d'accord et
bagheera suspension des allocations
familiales pour les parents bien
m'expliquer je comprenne
naturellement ça concerne qu'une
minorité puis andré maria naturellement
mais c'est toujours cette minorité qui
rend impossible la vie dans un
établissement
il suffit que vous ayez eu deux trois
quatre lycéens insupportable pour avoir
tout votre établissement qui est tiré
vers le bas
aujourd'hui qu'est-ce qui fait le
proviseur ou le principal il téléphone à
son collègue en disant j'en ai un qui
est terrifiant
le collègue répond moi aussi
en échange c'est pas comme ça que ça se
passe
c'est exactement comme ça que ça se
passe eh bien nous allons créer des
établissements d'internât de réinsertion
scolaire ce qui permettra d'abord vous
voyez quand même une sanction lourde
parce que celui qui va pas à l'école va
se retrouver un internat j'avais visité
avec luc chatel je veux rendre hommage
c'est un très bon ministre un
établissement de réinsertion pour des
enfants des lycéens très difficile on
avait été d'un ado de provence je me
souviens la journée commençait par
quatre heures de marche en montagne ce
qui mettait bien les idées en place et
les le corps enseignant m'avait dit
combien les jeunes qui se dépense est
comme ça trouve retrouver un équilibre
un sens des valeurs et parfois tenez
vous bien
j'admire beaucoup ces enseignants qui
avaient des volontaires pour aller dans
ces établissements parfois me dit il on
march 3 heures puis je fais la classe
donc là c'est un peu différente un peu
adapté ça apprend la vie en communauté
ça prend les règles ça prend à se lever
tôt et ça change complètement
l'atmosphère
ça change comment d'abord parce que les
établissements scolaires qui supporte
comme vous savez aujourd'hui ya parfois
des jeunes qui ont 19 ans qui sont en
troisième imaginez le gosse il ya 14 ans
qui est un copain de 19 ans non c'est
très très difficile je respecte beaucoup
le métier d'enseignant pas c'est pas
simple j'avais visité un lycée en cette
année où demande n'était de dolly siens
n'étaient pas là et il est en prison ce
qui était une cause d'absence justifiée
donc non mais imaginez pour l'enseignant
imaginé pour l'enseignant là me
semble-t-il
on apporte une réponse extrêmement
précises à ce qu'ils ont à dire ça coûte
cher
pas du tout ça coûte beaucoup moins cher
beaucoup moins cher c'est comme notre
histoire de cours élémentaire de cours
de cp plus c'est de l'argent bien sûr
mais ça coûte beaucoup moins cher que
d'avoir un échec scolaire que vous
trimballez pendant 15 ans et après des
gosses qui arrive pas à trouver un
emploi et à s'insérer faut savoir ce
qu'on veut
moi il me semble que c'est une mesure
extrêmement forte
alors j'ajoute que nous allons apporter
une réponse également aux décrocheurs je
vous demande d'être attentifs
ça va faire parler mais je crois qu'on
ne peut plus avoir chaque année cent
mille jeunes qui disparaissait
statistiques qui n'ont pas le bac
donc un diplôme qui maîtrise aucun des
savoirs qui est pas dans la nature qu'il
faut pas d'apprentissage que pas de
formation et qui ont pris depuis la
troisième la détestable habitude de quoi
la rue et de l'absentéisme
c'est ça les décrocheurs aujourd'hui que
la réponse peut décrocheurs qu'une alors
nous allons dire à ces cent mille
décrocheurs que c'est très simple à
partir de l'âge de 18 ans toute personne
qui n'aura pas son bac qui ne sera pas
en stage qui n'aura pas qui ne sera pas
un apprentissage qui n'a pas une
formation et bien lire affaires un
service militaire adapté
un service militaire adapté oui pourra
avoir son permis de conduire oui pourra
ré apprendre des règles de vie en commun
où il pourra ré apprendre simplement la
règle nous avons eu cette idée c'est
très simple le service militaire adapté
ça marche très bien
outre mer c'est une chance bon alors
c'est tout simple soit vous le savez un
emploi soit vous avez une formation soit
vous avez un stage soit vous êtes un
apprentissage soit vigilant service
militaire adapté service militaire avec
combien ça concernera deux jeunes je ne
sais pas et un potentiel 200 milles est
ce qu'il y aura cinq ans pin et ainsi
nous mettrons l'institution militaire en
situation de garder un lien avec la
nation
ils sont parfaitement capables
d'encadrer ces jeunes naturellement il
s'agira pas simplement d'une formation
militaire
j'ai parlé permis poids lourds permis de
conduire on peut parfaitement imaginer
annie apprentissage des langues sport à
haute dose et cetera
mais vous voyez qu à ce moment là les
chefs d'établissement aurons une réponse
et les décrocheurs auront aussi une
réponse je veux préciser que ce n'est
pas sur la base du volontariat
sinon voilà alors un mot pour terminer
en m'excusant d'être d'être d'avoir été
trop long sur l'enseignement supérieur
d'abord la loi d'autonomie
dix étaient insuffisantes bien sûr mais
il fallait pas gêné pour le faire avant
que j'arrive
j'aurais tellement heureux de pouvoir
faire la deuxième étape parce que la
première n'avait pas été fait pas
personne
et pourquoi n'avait pas été fait parce
que vous prononciez le mot autonomie
vous aviez immédiatement des
manifestations nous avons eu un an et
demi de manifestations et d'occupations
de si nous n'avons pas reculé
j'accepte parfaitement conditions on
aurait dû aller beaucoup plus loin sauf
de la part de ceux qui ont été beaucoup
moins loin parce que des projets
d'autonomie avorté j'en ai connu je me
souviens de luc ferry prononçant le mot
autonomie et jacques chirac lui
demandant de retirer son projet
immédiatement
donc nous avons fait voté l'autonomie
des universités c'est une grande fierté
il faut maintenant prévoir un acte deux
de l'autonomie
alors cet acte 2 qu'est-ce qui doit
décider
première chose je reconnais bien
volontiers olivier dont l'expression
hypocrisie et bien puisqu'il via
autonomie l'acte 2 doit permettre de
laisser la liberté aux universités
d'instituer des filières entre
guillemets sélective en leur sein et de
décider des conditions de recrutement
des enseignants qui sont des étudiants
qui souhaitent recruter
je suis désolé je ne vois pas pour
contre un modèle national chaque
un peu parfaitement décider des
conditions librement de recrutement des
étudiants
j'ajoute que c'est pas forcément la même
règle pour tous les enseignements à
l'intérieur de l'université
on peut parfaitement effectivement
prévoir dans une université des filières
plus sélectives et hautement sélective
mais c'est le problème de l'université
de la communauté pédagogique et des
représentants des associations
étudiantes
nous vous donnerons la liberté de cela
et pareil chaput andré pour les droits
d'inscription pour les droits
d'inscription vous en décider
simplement je souhaite que le ministre
donnait des universités puissent décider
d'un placement parce que je n'ai pas
l'intention que l'université se
caricature excusez moi c'est peut-être
un point de différence que nous avons
cher laurent pour moi la liberté ne va
pas sans la régulation il n'y a pas de
liberté sans régulation la liberté sans
la régulation c'est la loi du plus fort
c'est la loi de la jungle c'est le
contraire de l'état ce que veulent les
français c'est un état de droit où on
connaisse la règle ou y est un art vite
et où il y ait une régulation
regardez moi le le marché des matières
premières aujourd'hui bel exemple on est
passé d'un baril de pétrole atteint à
130 dollars le baril est au plus bas il
était à 27
voilà ce que donne et je vous garantis
que dans deux ans ils vont flamber
encore c'est pas ça que nous voulons par
la question de savoir si on est libéral
ou pas nous voulons la liberté et nous
voulons la régulation nous voulons les
deux je souhaite que les universités
puissent choisir les conditions de
sélection de recrutement de nos
étudiants
je souhaite les plus choisir les droits
qu'ils demandent dans un certain cadre
parce que sinon j'ai peur qu'ils aient
des excès et l'excès caricature la
liberté la liberté a besoin d'être
ordonnée voilà c'est la raison
d'ailleurs pour laquelle y compris cher
jean baptiste que nous proposons trois
cent mille fonctionnaires de moins
c'est une discussion très approfondie
que nous avons eues cher eric nous ne
disons pas qu'on veut plus d'état
manquerait plus que ça avec les risques
de sécurité avec les problèmes
d'immigration
avec les problèmes d'identité la
question pour nous n'est pas de
démanteler l'état français la question
c'est d'avoir un état qui sache faire
son travail qui n'ont pas j'aime pas la
vie des gens mais qui les protège pour
cela on a besoin d'un étang on va pas
passer du tout socialiste à la table
rase qui conduira à quoi à la révolte
des français qui ont besoin des protégés
et on a besoin de régulation
donc ma réponse sur l'université sur
l'autonomie me semble-t-il si vous avez
le droit de recruter comme vous le
désirez ici vous avez le droit de fixer
des droits d'inscription il me semble
que là on passe même directement à
l'époque 3 de l'autonomie j'ajoute un
dernier point je voudrais que chaque
université puisse développer ce que
j'appelle des incubateurs d'entreprises
sur chaque campus
parce que il faut absolument réconcilier
l'université avec l'entreprise et je ne
connais pas de meilleure façon de
réconcilier l'université avec
l'entreprise que de permettre à des
jeunes étudiants de créer leur propre
entreprise sur le campus qui les a
formés et je rêverais d'un de paysage
universitaire française où chaque
université puis avoir son incubateur
d'entreprises
on va me dire tu t'inspires d'un exemple
américain oui on a le droit
on peut aussi s'inspirer de temps en
temps de ce qui marche on n'est pas
obligé de s'inspirer que de ce qui
marche pas vous souvenez vous connaissez
très bien cette histoire qu à stanford
au lendemain de la guerre il y avait
plus un choix et il est terminé et pour
vous et ils ont une idée absolument
géniale comme il y avait plus de sous
mais beaucoup de places
ils ont dit on va réserver une part du
campus pour donner des locaux à nous à
ceux de nos étudiants les meilleurs qui
vont fonder leur boîte là dedans y ait
deux inconnus qui ont fait un certain
certains chemins qui s'appelle violette
c'était très copains été nommé pas car
oui c'est comme ça que ça ça ça a
commencé
et ç'a permis et bien toutes les
universités françaises devraient pouvoir
non seulement donner des locaux prêtés
des locaux à des étudiants qui veulent
créer leur start up sur le campus
parce qu'ils se rencontrent et un copain
avec iso une idée
mais bien mieux je souhaite que les
universités puissent investir dans des
start up
quelle est la meilleure façon d'aider
des étudiants et ont réconcilié ainsi un
drame français qui est la séparation
entre la recherche fondamentale et la
recherche appliquée ou celui qui fait de
la recherche fondamentale se bouchent le
nez en parlant de celui qui fait la
recherche appliquée mais ya pas de
recherche appliquée s'il n'ya pas de
recherche fondamentale c'est un
continuum et il faut absolument des
sectarismes les filières en france parce
que c'est des chercheurs parce que ces
chefs d'entreprise et ainsi au
réconcilie le monde universitaire et le
monde de l'entreprise
bon mes chers amis voilà j'en ai terminé
je voudrais quand même vous dire que on
a fait un effort pour approfondir c'est
pas fini on va continuer mais c'était
pas facile parce que c'est un sujet où
la droite et le centre ont souvent été
mal à l'aise mises à part quelques
pionniers sur pierre andré je pense
qu'il faut ne faire aucun complexe et
d'avoir aucun tabou shirani et qu'en
même temps il faut se fier de ce qu'on a
fait même pas avoir peur de dire
effectivement laurent quand on n'a pas
été assez loin ou voir même quand on
s'est trompé
pour que l'alternance de 2010 est
présente un projet éducatif est un
projet universitaire qui soit adaptée à
la situation de la france
maintenant annie genevard va vous
soumettre 10 questions merci de votre
patience
merci de votre